(transition whooshing)
- In this project, we
put capacitive sensing
on top of robotic skins.
Traditionally, robotic fingers are rigid.
In this project, we are using silicone
with flexible electrodes
made out of copper,
which are connected to a
capacitive sensing chip
that is normally made
for smartphone capacitive touch sensors.
This approach makes it
affordable and scalable.
- We use computational design
to fabricate our electrodes.
And this particular
design has the capability
to enable computer
vision on the electrodes
because we have a fairly high definition
and we can do blob tracking
or detection of a slippery
problem in a robotic touch.
- To laser cut our design, we
export the file and load them
onto this laser cut control software.
Here we can see two objects.
One will be vertically
placed on the robotic finger.
It corresponds to the
x-axis of the sensor.
The other will come perpendicularly
to measure the y-axis data.
These will be combined
to show the whole picture
that has enough data for blob detection
and signal processing.
- Now that we are ready,
we can put the Kapton tape on the glass
and some copper tape,
and we can engrave it using this laser.
I'm going to put it in the machine.
(gentle music)
And now I can start engraving.
(gentle music continues)
Now that we have engraved the copper tape,
we can peel off the electrode
and place it directly
on the silicone finger.
Then we can encapsulate it
either with this piece of latex glove
or we can dip it in silicone.
And eventually, the idea is to have
a fully sensitive robotic hand
that can recognize objects
that it's touching, recognize
when the objects are falling,
and adding more intelligence
to the robotic hand.
- Infusing increased intelligence
and autonomous function
in robotic hands to lead
to significant enhancement
in various applications,
such as manufacturing,
healthcare, and space exploration.
We are really excited to
shape this future reality.